- WHERE WERE YOU WHEN YOU FIRST
DISCOVERED YOUR WIFE'S BODY?
- BUT GOT OFF ON A TECHNICALITY.
- SHE WEARING EVIDENCE?
- NO.
- I GAINED MY FREEDOM,
BUT I LOST EVERYTHING ELSE,
EXCEPT, OF COURSE,
MY FAMILY NAME.
NOW, I'M SERVING THE WORST
SENTENCE OF ALL...
- [screaming]
- MOVING BACK IN WITH MY FATHER.
THIS IS HOUSE OF ARMOND.
[insane laughter]
- PAPA, HAVE YOU SEEN MY
E-READER?
- I HAVE NOT, MY PIGLET.
- YOU'RE SO OLD.
ALL YOU DO IS WORK
WITH DEAD ANIMALS.
IT'S CREEPY.
MY FATHER'S A TAXIDERMIST, AND
I'M AN ANIMAL PLASTIC SURGEON.
COULD WE BE ANY MORE DIFFERENT?
- SEE, LOOK, LOOK--
LOOK AT THIS GUY.
SEE?
I BROUGHT HIM BACK TO LIFE.
- ARE THOSE EYES PERMANENT?
[maniacal laughter]
- NO, NO, I JUST--
I JUST STUCK THOSE ON THERE
SO I'D HAVE SOMETHING
TO REFER TO.
- UGH, THIS IS SO UNFAIR.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M BACK
IN THIS HOUSE OF HORRORS.
[eerie music]
- I LOVE YOU EVEN IF YOU ARE
A MURDERER.
- WELL, I'M NOT A MURDERER,
PAPA!
WHY DOES EVERYONE HAVE TO KEEP
BRINGING UP MY WIFE'S MURDER?
LET'S JUST LET
SLEEPING DOGS LIE.
- HOW'S THE MAN OF THE MOMENT?
- I'M GRUMPY, PAPA.
I WANT TO BE LEFT ALONE.
- WELL, IN THAT CASE,
WHY DON'T WE HAVE A PARTY?
- NOBODY WANTS TO SEE ME.
THEY ALL THINK I'M A MURDERER.
- INVITE YOUR GOOD FRIEND
KELSEY GRAMMER OVER.
I COULD MAKE SOME BAGEL BITES.
- CAN YOU JUST LEAVE MY ROOM,
PLEASE.
- DON'T BE SUCH A BABY.
- DETECTIVE SMART?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE?
- YOU AND ME HAVE TO TALK.
[dramatic music]
- [scream]